I just feel like I'm just sick and tired
of hearing about this trauma Fair like
you're not the only one everyone's got
trauma no matter if you're a man woman
black white don't matter brother
everyone's got their own draw my soul
bro you're not you're not special that's
just the way I see it and I I really
just don't I just ignore when people
come out with that kind of talk I just
ignore it because at the end of the day
like just a lot of times it's like when
women go through stuff it's like the
world has to stop like and it's just
like guys when we go through stuff is we
get told to man up so why don't you
woman up right yeah that's just my
that's why I take on it and that's it